bonsoir gabriela bravo merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur arte
france ce soir donc brésil argentine
chili venezuela pérou ça fait beaucoup
de pays avant de se focaliser sur une
nation ou une autre globalement comment
expliquer cette situation est ce qu'on
peut mettre ça sur le compte des
variants brésilien il ya masioni est
amazonien comme on vient de le voir sur
le sujet de guillemin ruse russie ou
bien est-ce que c'est plus politique
publié un peu d'un mélange des deux d'un
côté il ya les variantes l'arrivée des
du variant britannique mais c'est
surtout les variantes brésilienne qui en
fait beaucoup de mal à l'amérique du sud
parce que selon les épidémiologistes
latino américains les vrais cl c'est un
terreau où ils peuvent se développer des
différents variant puisque l'épidémie
est complètement hors de contrôle dans
ce pays donc aussi il faut savoir quel
bray cl clp qui à la frontière la plus
grande avec la plus grande quantité des
pays de l'amérique du sud
donc c'est varions le variant dé manaus
le variant de rien des généraux ont
commencé à passer les frontières
ça s'est envolé mais il ya l'autre volet
que c'est les politiques d chaque pays
ce qui on a vu c'est que après un nom
des pandémies déconne à virus les pays
ils sont commencé à relâcher les mesures
sanitaires car c'est là que c'est
beaucoup de crises sociales les
enfermant le couvre-feu et tous les
mesures de restriction de liberté
il savait provoqué aussi dont certains
pays d crise sociale majeure donc les
nouvelles variantes brésilienne et des
larmes en 2d relâchement des mesures
sanitaires ont provoqué une flambée de
l'épidémie en temps l'amérique du sud
plusieurs causes à cette flambée de kobe
en amérique du sud
on se focalise sur l'argentine qui a
commencé sa campagne vaccinale
le 29 décembre mais selon trois millions
de personnes ont été vaccinées pourquoi
on peut parler de l'art gentil mais
c'est le problème de plusieurs pays de
l'amérique latine de l'amérique du sud
et l problème c'est que les pays riches
les pays développés ont accaparé le
marché des vaccins les pays développés
représentera 16% de la population et ils
sont achetés soit 100% des vaccins donc
les pays du sud n'ont pas accès à une
grande quantité et des vaccins et soit
l'argentine le brésil paraguay
ils sont commencé une campagne de
vaccination mais sinon pas les vaccins
il ne peut pas avancer si rapidement les
seuls pays qui qui sait de marque de
sens et le chili le pays qui a pu
négocier avec un ou à la vente des
vaccins avec différents laboratoires et
qu' il ya eu un échange avec des
laboratoires chinois ce qui a permis d
pouvoir accéder un grand nombre des
vaccins et on voit que celle troisième
pays au monde les plus vaccinée en ce
moment 3 % de la population chilienne
vacciner
troisième derrière israël est derrière
la grande bretagne mais pourtant le
président chilien sebastian pinera
envisage le report des élections
constitutionnel et il manque la sarre
confinement strict comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquer exactement ça on l'a
appelée la padox chilienne c'est à dire
que les chiliens se sont fait vacciner
massivement et ils sont et se sont
complètement relâché les messieurs
sanitaires ont été complètement relâchée
ces qui a provoqué une flambée d
l'épidémie dans ces dernières semaines
ces dernières jours parce que il faut
savoir que le vaccin n'est pas une
baguette magique qui fait disparaître
tout de suite
l'épidémie il faut avoir déjà les deux
vaccins et après il faut attendre deux
semaines pour pouvoir avoir l'immunité
néanmoins les chiliens et se sont sentis
protéger le vaccin n'ont pas recette et
succès pour cette campagne de
vaccination et ils sont aurait lâché
dans le port des masques dont aussi la
distanciation social c'est qui a donné
comme résultat une explosion des cas et
une flambée de l'épidémie
ouais tout ce qui n'est pas très
encourageant et évidemment pour pour les
semaines à venir
un message d alerte donc pour pour les
personnes qui se font qui se font
vacciner évidemment mais pour revenir
également sur ce qui se passe en
amérique du sud il ya les scandales des
vaccinations vieilles pies des ministres
qui devance la population grâce à leurs
réseaux ça fait couler beaucoup d'encre
comment se positionne la population par
rapport à cette problématique en
argentine notamment avec les
passe-droits c'est monnaie courante
ce qu on a vu on tend différents pays à
l'argentine l'équateur le brésil même le
venezuela des personnes qu'ils n'ont pas
respecté les propres politiques
sanitaires qui ont été imposées à leurs
citoyens
qu'est ce qui se passe ça ça fait très
mal à la démocratie
ça fait m ça fait penser aux gens cette
idée d tous corrompus
une classe politique qui préfère entre
guillemets c'est sauver tout seul on
détriment de sa propre population
c'est qui fait très mal à la démocratie
en amérique latine mais aussi sacré d un
conflit social parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la sortie de cette
pandémie va faire peut-être va jouer un
rôle majeur dans les événements après
pandémie c'est à dire on va vivre une
crise économique et sociale et le
comportement des dirigeants de
l'amérique du sud va était est scruté
par le citoyen et des scandales comme
les vaccins vip bien aussi entaché cette
l'idée d une classe politique corrompue
et qui ne se soucie pas des ses propres
concitoyens autres pays le venezuela
avec le président nicholas maduro qui
propose du pétrole en échange de
vaccins en amérique du sud plus
qu'ailleurs les vaccins sont
géopolitique exactement c'est un enjeu
majeur en ce moment d'abord parce que la
sortie de la pandémie dès la sortie de
la pandémie va dépendre entre guillemets
la tête des plusieurs dirigeants comment
et sans comme ils sont arrivés à
surmonter
comme ils sont mis des politiques on
pratique pour pouvoir gérer leur pays
donc d'un côté il ya le venezuela que
comme je l'avais dit ne peut pas
s'approvisionner des vaccins parce que
ils sont été accaparées par les pays
riches mais il ya tous les pays de la
région de l'amérique latine de
l'amérique du sud qui sont qui cherchent
à s'approvisionner de vaccins pour
pouvoir sortie de ce pont demi qui va
sûrement coûté le poste à nombreux
dirigeants politiques de la région
merci gabriela bravo d'avoir répondu à
nos questions rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste de l'amérique
latine